the prophet Muhammad S.I wasallam told
us whoever builds a mosque for Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah and we know the great reward
that will not only be gained but rather
will fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shah in the Masid whenever
someone learns something in the Masid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your
scale
how are you guys doing recently the CEO
of the sapiens Institute Hamza Andrea
zorus has engaged in a debate with a
Zionist sympathizer in Ireland a country
which for the most part has been on side
uh with the Palestine issue because
they've suffered their own fair share of
colonialism I think there is a vicarious
sympathy that the Irish people feel Vis
A the Palestinian
issue and the person who he was debating
with presented not but
spous and specious claims of a sophistic
Kind let's take a look at some of those
exchanges and come back and respond
in kind let me ask you a question why
are you racist let me tell you why cuz
you're talking about October the 6th
where is your condemnation of the
equivalent 5 October the 7th that were
inflicted on the Palestinians from 2008
to 2020 where is your condemnation of
that you talk about October the 6th as
if everything was Rosy and peaceful
Israel has an aparte system that arounds
65 laws no less than 65 laws that
discriminate against Arab Israelis and
the Palestinians you have illegal
occupation you're not saying nothing
about what happened before October the
7th with regards to its reality where is
your condemnation of the equivalent of
five October the 7th since 2008 where is
your condemnation why the moral
asymmetry is it because you're racist
you're either ignorant or you're racist
as you saw with that particular clipping
of the video and the entire video you
can watch on Hamza Andrea Z's
channel uh which you can just write his
name Hamza zorus on YouTube and you
should subscribe to his
channel is that someone may say this is
a a strong claim to state that or to
suggest that this man is a racist or
that somebody who supports the Zionist
cause is a racist but I think that is an
honest opinion and I think that is a
natural inference and I'll tell you why
if one unequivocally and without any
exception agrees and supports the state
of Israel which is predicated on racial
superiority and the evidence of that is
found clearly in the works of the
zionists all the way from Herzel and
wise men and so on to our present day
and which has as a country laws which
intentionally discriminate against
Palestinian people we've spoken at
length about them for example apartheid
laws uh like the law of return then this
isn't natural inference because it is a
prerequisite for believing in these
kinds of laws or supporting entities
which Advocate and or impose laws like
this to actually believe or accept or
acques or
plate uh somehow this
idea of a racial superiority or uh
inequality of some kind and that's
racism where you are
prioritizing and
ex you know exceptional liing one group
of people over another because of their
race it was a shambolic performance by
this Zionist sympathizer and a wonderful
and fantastic performance by H Andreas
sources I'm sure you will be watching
the debate and I particularly liked his
comment about why are you asking us to
condemn October 7th when you haven't
condemned the equivalent of 5 October
7th since
2014 hey you are you wasting your time
on social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even
more